pour en parler nous sommes avec francis
choisel historien de la constitution
bonsoir francis choisel à merci d'être
avec nous avec vous on va parler de ce
fameux 49,3 une arme législative
nucléaire comme on la surnomme parfois
d'ailleurs c'est un surnom qui lui est
bien approprié salon vous c'est une arme
qui n'est pas forcément du clair mais je
trouve que c'est surtout une arme qui
n'est pas adaptée à la situation
ou du moins pas adaptée à celle ci oui
la situation actuelle c'est à dire que
on nous dit qu'il ya trop d'amendements
que le débat va être trop long il faut
raccourcir le débat mais le 49-3 n'est
pas né n'a jamais été prévu pour
raccourcir un débat il a été prévu pour
empêcher pour supprimer un vote
donc je ne comprends pas bien si je
comprends un peu mais je veux dire on ne
comprend pas bien pourquoi il ya tout ce
débat autour de 49 3 pourquoi on brandit
la menace du 49-3 pour raccourcir des
débats alors que ça n'est pas son objet
et qu'il y à un autre article le 44 3
qui s'appelle le vote bloqué et qui lui
permettrait de voter mais de raccourcir
les débats
effectivement c'est intéressant vous
êtes en train de nous dire que
finalement le 49 3 et détourné de son
utilisation de sa vocation première
ça pourrait être ça détourne et suit des
tournées sur une critique
moi je dirais plutôt que c'est comme
prendre une canne à pêche pour aller à
la chasse ou prend d'une fusée pour
aller à la pêche
si on réussit à s'en servir pour pêcher
pour chasser en n'ayant pas le bon outil
pourquoi pas au passé mais mais ce n'est
pas ce que ce que
je voulais dire c'est que il faut
chercher pourquoi on utilise cet outil
là plutôt que l'autre l'autre le vote
bloqué les simples c'est le gouvernement
peut décider de faire voter sur son
texte et qu'il n'y ait plus
d'amendements et la constitution dit
même tout ou partie du texte
c'est à dire que demain matin d'hier je
mets en oeuvre 44,3 plus de discussions
vote
et pourquoi ne le ferait-il pas dans ce
cas parce qu'il a peut-être un problème
de vote
peut-être parce que il a envie d'agiter
tous les médias vous moi autour du 49 3
est-ce qu'en l'espèce c'est un scénario
quand même qui vous semble inéluctable
on est dans une situation assez inédite
des milliers et les milliers
d'amendements plus de 40000 déposé
essentiellement par la france 1-1
soumises
effectivement ce qu'ils ont bu le disent
eux même de bloquer ces débats qu'est ce
qui reste comme alternative finalement
au gouvernement l'espèce c'est ce que je
vous disais c'est d'utiliser un autre
article le cas le 43 peu importe son
numéro d'ailleurs c'est à dire le vote
bloqué vous disiez comme tout le monde
il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup d'
obstruction d'ailleurs l'obstruction ne
me choque pas plus que l'utilisation
éventuelle du 49-3 où nous 44,3
l'obstruction et j'allais dire est
vieille comme le monde je caricature un
peu mais la première fois que
l'obstruction été utilisés c'est ce sont
les irlandais au parlement britannique
qui ont décidé alors non pas de mettre
des tonnes d'amendements mais de faire
des discours fleuves et ils ont même
pris la bible utilisée la bible et ils
ont réussi comme ça une fois à faire
durer 26 heures une c'est une séance
donc l'objectif c'est l'obstruction
alors l'autre solution qu'est ce que ces
basses et les gilets jaunes ont bloqué
les carrefours les la cgt à bloquer les
transports
ben allal un france insoumise
bloch le parlement et ce qu'ils essayent
c'est d'obtenir un résultat politique
par ce blocage
alors j'ai dit grève c'est que c'est
l'équivalent d'une rave c'est
l'équivalent d'une guérilla en anglais
on peut on distribue sting ses dires
flibuste cessé de la guérilla les
irlandais en tout cas on réussit à faire
à obtenir dans les années 1870 1880
ils ont réussi à obtenir que leur cause
soit écoutée par le board parlement
britannique voilà donc c'est parfois un
bon calcul
on peut se scandaliser qu'il n'y a pas
de discussions mais je reviens si si on
veut supprimer les amendements le
gouvernement ne peut alors s'il est
utilisé ce que ça serait justement
vraiment la fin des débats
en l'espèce oui ce serait là ce serait
la fin des débats mais ce sera surtout
la fin du vote
c'est à dire que le prince le principe
du 49 3 c'est que l'origine du 49 3 en
1958 c'était d'éviter la valse des
ministères parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
y avait un texte
quand ils étaient rejetés le ministère
le gouvernement se croyait obligé de
démissionner
donc on le 43 son objectif cessé de dire
au député attendait c'est un texte
important est ce que franchement vous
voulez renverser le gouvernement sur ce
sujet l'habitat sujet mineur et donc on
leur dit voilà si vous ne disposez pas
de motion de censure le texte passe donc
voyez c'est pour empêcher que les
gouvernements tombent
parce que presque par hasard des fois
parce qu'un texte mineurs et renverser
la sepa texte final peut-être justement
c'est une utilisation année assez
inédite on sait que monsieur rocard
l'avait utilisé à de nombreuses reprises
je crois 28 fois mais c'était différent
il avait une majorité extrêmement
fébrile françois hollande évidemment
enfin d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres
gouvernements l'ont utilisé mais souvent
pour calmer une majorité turbulente là
c'est effectivement oui totalement
différent c'est rouge habituellement
qu'il est destinée non pas à museler
l'opposition
parce qu'on peut avoir le 49-3 la preuve
avec des discussions avant ça ne raconte
pas la discussion s'est empêché vonn je
le répète nous avait dit sur aucune
chaîne excusera dit sur la vôtre je le
répète c'est c'est le vote qui est
supprimé ça n'est pas là ce n'est pas la
discussion est donc le du point de vue
de la majorité
ça peut arranger aussi la majorité c'est
à dire que vous avez des députés qui
retournent dans les circonscriptions qui
seront disputés font que vous votiez
faut pas que vous étiez
et donc quand tu es quand yale 49,3
n'ont pas voté ils ont simplement à ne
pas censurer le gouvernement
et donc ils peuvent retourner vers leurs
électeurs les tomates
ils disent ils avaient voté non j'ai pas
voté j'ai simplement refusé de renverser
le gouvernement et donc la suppression
du vote
elle n'est pas lié je pense à la crainte
du gouvernement de ne pas faire passer
le texte
sa majorité suffisamment large mais
peut-être qu'il considère que ça ferait
désordre
s'il y avait un certain nombre de gens
que tous les médias appellerait des
frondeurs comme du temps de françois
hollande alors qu'il y en a dix qui en
était un scanner 21 des 50
ça ferait désordre là on ne les verra
pas on ne les verra pas parce que dans
le vote du 49-3 ne votent que alors
d'abord il faut qu'une censure dans une
motion de censure qui soient déposées et
on ne comptabilise que le nombre de ceux
qui votent la censure tous les autres
tous les autres ils n'ont pas voté
contre la censure il c'est l'équivalent
d'une abstention
ils n'ont rien fait c'est cdu course
pilate en fait oui donc ça peut arranger
la majorité ça peut agir s'agissait pour
les jeux je dis les choses de façon un
peu méchante mais des gens que les
quatre conscience il qu'ils disent je ne
veux pas en toute conscience voter cela
elle vous demande pas de voter pour vous
demande pas de voitures nous devrons
tout simplement de ne pas renverser le
gouvernement
on a devant prix versés en tout cas
francis loisel d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france historien de la
constitution dans quelques instants